I don't know, I've just never
really been into porn.
I mean, the idea of people
getting paid to
have sex, it's just...
it's awful, it's never
ever turned me on.
Totally, like, I hear you,
but trust me this is--
It's just different.
It's not like
porny-porn, it's...
It feels like
real sex.
It just happens
to be, literally,
from the woman's
point of view.
I'm curious,
I guess.
Yeah.
( bed springs squeaking )
( man groaning )
Oh...
( bed springs squeaking )
( phone ringing )
Oh...
( man grunting )
( man )
Move down, move down.
( woman )
Ow, you're on my hair.
Okay, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Did you ever see that
movie, "Spanglish"?
What?
Call me
Adam Sandler.
Can you-- can you--
Move your--
bend your leg back more?
No.
Oh, all right,
sorry.
Okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay.
Ohh!
Oh...
( exhaling )
Oh... oh...
Don't, don't,
don't, don't, don't.
Okay.
( man )
Can I get a $75 bid now?
At $75...
Did you show
me this so
I would think
guys were gross
and I would lez-out
with you?
It worked.
♪♪